Ahudubillahiminas Shaytana regime Bismillahir Rahmanir Rahim Allahumma salli Allah saydana Muhammadin Wa ala ali saydana Muhammadin Kamasallaita wa salamta wa baraktawa rahimtawa tarahamta ala Ibrahim wa ala ali Ibrahim fil alamina inna Kahamidun Majid Rabbish Rahli Sadri Wa yasserli Amri Wahlul Uqdatamillisani of Kahukawli Assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatu
We completed the linguistic study of the first four verses of Surah Al-Fateha.
So now we have, after giving us an introduction of who Allah is through the first, or rather the beginning verses, then he says, Iya kana abudu wa iya kana sta'in.
It is only you that we worship or willingly enslave ourselves to.
And it is only you that we seek help from.
Now here, there's something really interesting in this verse.
If you notice, there is a complete change of tone over here.
So the previous verses, they were all in the third person, right?
They were informational.
So bismillah rahman rahim.
begin with the name of Allah extremely merciful intensely merciful all praise and glory belongs to Allah who is the master of all universes or everything that is known the abundant the abundantly merciful the consistently merciful owner of a time when the dead of submission falls due so these are all statements if you notice they're all in the third person
in which Allah is just basically informing us about who He is.
But then, He suddenly changes the tone and He turns it into a second person conversation.
He turns it into a dua, as if we are now speaking directly with Him.
it is only you we worship and it is only you we turn to for help the tone of this verse is not that Allah is the one that we worship and Allah is the one that we turn to help it's not in the third person it's as if we are in direct conversation with Allah at this point and this is a beautiful linguistic tool in the Arabic language that is called Il-Tifaat
which is a sudden change in the pronoun of the speaker, or the one that is being spoken to.
So Allah constantly changes the conversation in the Quran from third person to first person, then to second person, and then back to third person, right?
And you can see this in almost every single surah.
He sometimes refers to Himself using I, sometimes He uses we,
right?
Sometimes he uses him.
These are all linguistic tools to not only keep the reader alert and awake, but also a mechanism to highlight what Allah wants from us.
So in the case of Surah Al-Fateha, you can see that the tone now suddenly changes to a du'a, it changes to a supplication.
It is only you we worship and it is only you we turn to for help.
And who is the one saying that?
It is you and I that are saying that.
So we are now in direct conversation with Allah.
And this style of switching suddenly from third person to second person is a means of letting us know that this is in fact what Allah wants from us.
You understand?
When we say ...
because this is all revelation coming from Allah, right?
We are not the authors of Quran.
So this is all revelation coming from Allah.
So now imagine a book like Quran, something so meaningful.
How is Allah to have this conversation with us where suddenly now He wants us, while He's describing Himself, He wants us to know what He wants from us.
So by changing his tone to Iya kanabudu wa ya kanasta'in, Allah is expressing His intention of wanting us to say that we willingly worship you and we freely give up our freedom and desires to become your slaves.
In other words, Allah is not commanding us into slavery by saying Istaabadu anfusikum li Enslave yourselves to Me.
Instead, He wants us to say Iya kanabudu It is only you
that we want to worship.
In other words, Allah is asking us to reach this conclusion of our wudiya on our own, through the study of the previous three verses.
The idea is that when we truly understand the meaning of Alhamdulillahi Rabbil Alameen, when we truly understand the meaning of Ar-Rahmanir Raheem and when we truly understand the meaning of Maliki Yawmid Deen,
And when we recognize what an incredibly loving, merciful, and powerful Rabb Allah is, our natural and logical conclusion to that understanding has to be .
You see?
Our natural response has to be a willing desire of submission.
So the idea here is that if you haven't reached that conclusion all by yourself, then don't say it.
So Allah is not forcing us to say it.
This is us saying it to Allah out of our own free will.
So I wanted to start the explanation of this verse by making that distinction.
Now let's look at this verse linguistically.
The first word is iyaqa, which means only you.
So, linguistically, iyaka excludes everything and everyone except the object of the conversation.
So, think of it like a clause of exclusivity.
So, what we're saying is you, only you, and no one else but you, iyaka.
The next word is...
naabudu which means we worship and naabudu comes from the word ibada which we all know means worship which in turn comes from the root word abd which means slave now what is the connection between worship and slavery what's the relationship there the relationship is that worship is a demonstration of one's slavery
Worship or Aibada is a demonstration of one's acceptance of slavery.
It is a proof of one's slavery.
It is an act of devotion and dedication that establishes one's slavery.
So I'll give you a very basic example.
if I stood on a on the top of a building and I screamed at the top of my lungs for two hours that you know I'm a slave of Allah I'm a slave of Allah I'm a slave of Allah but then when it's time for prayer if I do not pray I can say that I'm a slave of Allah all day long but did I back it up did I prove that statement no
So our worship, our ibada is actually proof and evidence of the fact that we are in fact the slaves of Allah.
Otherwise it's just an empty claim.
That's how these two words are connected together.
So it means it is only you and no one else but you that we worship or willingly enslave ourselves to.
Now, what's really powerful about this concept is that by desiring this enslavement of Allah, we are essentially desiring freedom from everything else.
Becoming the slaves of Allah provides freedom from every other slavery of this world.
So essentially what we're recognizing through iyaka na'budu is that we do not want to become the slave of this dunya.
We want to become the slave of Allah and in the process of that slavery, through the process of that slavery, we want to free ourselves from everything else.
So by recognizing our ubu diya to Allah, what we get is the huriya, which is true freedom.
In completing the ubu diya to Allah, we are no longer slaves to ourselves and that's a truly free person.
If I can control myself, then I'm a slave to myself.
Somebody can say, I'm free, I'm free.
But then when the food shows up, they just cannot stop themselves.
And that's not freedom as far as the Muslim is concerned, right?
He's not Abdullah at that point.
He's Abdul Hawa.
He's a slave of his own passions.
So Abdullah, the slave of Allah, is that when the situation arises, he has taqwa of Allah.
He has that mindfulness of the presence of Allah.
It's not that the temptation goes away, right?
The desire is still there because we're all humans, so the Shahwa might still be there, but the slave of Allah, the Abdullah can control it because he's not the slave of his passion, he is the Sayyid of it, right?
He's not the Abd of his passion, he is the Sayyid of his passion, he is the master of it.
That is someone who is really free, you know, that's Dahur.
But this level of mastery can only be attained through the slavery of Allah.
So, you know, there are many kinds of slaveries in that respect, right?
The tongue is the same, right?
There are so many people who just can't stop backbiting.
They just can't stop gossiping.
I mean, you can tell them, you can point it out to them a million times, but they just can't stop.
I mean, it's just amazing.
And in most cases, they're not even aware of it.
I mean, I'm sure I do things like that all the time, but because this just exists within us, this inability to control our tongues, to speak badly about others, to say things that we really shouldn't be saying.
And I'm just guilty as the next person.
But this is the human weakness that people find it hard to control.
We find it hard to control these things.
So learning to control the tongue is also a major thing in Islam.
So when we say Iya kana abudu, it is only you we desire to enslave ourselves to, what's implicit in that dua is that we are essentially desiring freedom from the enslavement of everything else.
Everything that is dunya, money, houses, cars, children,
food, these branded clothes, friends, relatives, I mean there are millions and millions of shackles that we wear around ourselves and you know and we don't even realize it and what the slavery of Allah does is that it frees us from all those shackles.
The next thing that I want to point out about this verse is the fact that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he uses the plural form here
He says, Iyaka naarbudu.
It is only you we worship.
Now, let me ask you a question.
The majority of the time when we pray, are we praying by ourselves or in a group?
Generally, we're praying by ourselves, right?
So then, can I say when I'm praying by myself, can I just say, Iyaka arbudu.
It is only you that I worship.
I mean, wouldn't that be more logical?
So then can I change it to the singular form when I'm just praying by myself?
No, I cannot.
It's not permissible.
It's not allowed.
I cannot change it.
I have to use the plural form.
So that's very interesting, right?
Why did Allah fix the statement in the plural form?
Scholars explain that by fixing the statement in the plural form,
What Allah is emphasizing is this importance of unity.
Allah is emphasizing this concept of unity, that even when I pray by myself, I do not speak just for myself.
I speak on behalf of the whole Ummah, on behalf of my entire community.
I say, .
because the ultimate way to establish unity is through the worship of Allah that's why they say that a family that prays together stays together a community that prays together sticks together so the message in this verse and the following verses is to be united to stay united as one unit as one family one community one nation
so Allah has forced this idea of of this togetherness you know so when I'm doing my prayers I am just naturally praying for you when you're doing your prayer you're praying for me even when you're praying alone so this plural form this unity this the sense of brotherhood the sense of millah ummah right all of this is just
just present in this plural form of nabudu.
So we say iya ka nabudu, it is you that we worship.
And the next thing we say is iya ka nastain, it is only you that we seek assistance from.
Now the word nastain, it comes from istaana, which in turn then comes from the root word aun, and it means assistance.
Now, there are many other words in Arabic for help, right?
There is one common word is Nasr.
There is also Musaida, there is Najdah.
There are all these different kinds of help.
But these are all different kinds of help.
So Nasr is a type of help that has a greater sense of urgency to it.
Nasr is the kind of help that we ask for.
It's the kind of help that we seek in emergency situations.
Major, major things, right?
When the help of Allah arrives at the most difficult of times, understand that victory will be near.
When the help of Allah arrives and you are victorious in battles, right?
Again, major help.
Keep us steadfast and help us over the nation of disbelievers.
Major emergency situation, major challenge.
So when I'm in a situation where I cannot do anything to get myself out of that, then I need somebody else to do it for me.
And in those kind of emergency situations, the word nasr would be used.
The word own is used for small matters it's the help that I need in little, little things, right?
So, I need a glass of water I can get up and get it myself, but if you're just right next to the cooler, I can say, Hey, can you get it?
me a glass of water and if you bring me that glass of water what you did is you assisted me right that's aun it's seeking assistance in daily tasks little little things so why is this distinction made in Surah Al-Fateha where the word aun is used instead of Nasr it's because a true believer is someone who turns to Allah subhana wa ta'ala all the time
that's the quality of a true believer he turns to Allah for everything for all the little little things in his life you understand he doesn't just think of Allah in major situations he remembers Allah in the little little things all throughout his day you know like a lover that remembers the beloved all the time and this is exactly what we find in the daily routine of our Prophet
He woke up in the morning.
What was the first thing he did?
The second he woke up, he praised Allah.
Alhamdulillah hilladi ahyaana baada amaatana wa ilaihin nushur.
He went to the restroom to relieve himself.
Audubillahi minna rajas sinna jis al khabith al mukhtish shaitaan arrajeen.
He sought the protection of Allah from shaitaan.
Right?
He got on his horse.
SubhanAllah thee sakhara lanaha zawa ma kunna lahumu krineen wa inna ila rabbin alaman kaliboon.
Before he would start eating his food, Bismillahir Rahmanir Rahim.
As soon as he finished eating his food, Alhamdulillahir Rabbila Alameen.
He stepped out of his house to leave somewhere.
Bismillahi tawakkala ala Allahi wala hula wala kuwata illa billahila alilaazi.
is used for seeking assistance of Allah constantly in even in the most tiny matters so the first reason for using our own is this idea of constant remembrance the second reason we constantly seek his assistance is because we recognize that we are not the ideal slaves right we understand that we are weak human beings
who desperately require assistance every step of the way, in every little thing that we do.
Because we are dominated by our desires of this world.
We are challenged by innumerable distractions every single waking moment of our lives.
So we are constantly walking this slippery slope.
So we know that it's not going to be easy to maintain our Abhudiya.
because we are surrounded by the worst four enemies that are constantly working against us.
First is our nafs, our soul that is weak to begin with.
Then we have this dunya, the temptations of this world.
Then we have hawa, which is our overwhelming desires and passions.
And then there is Shaitaan himself.
So we are surrounded on all sides by these powerful enemies.
And we recognize that and so we admit that our Abu Diya and our servitude is not going to be worthy of Rabbul Alameen.
But we're willing to try, right?
We're still willing to try.
And in that trying, we're going to need our master's assistance in every little thing that we do.
So when we fail over and over again, we will still constantly need Allah to pick us up, because only He can protect and assist us.
So, iya kana abudu wa iya kanastaayin It is only You that we worship, but then it is only You that we seek assistance from in every little thing that we do.
So the statement is made-up of these two parts.
Iyya kanaarbudu is making that willing commitment to Allah.
That yes, I do want to become your slave so that I can be free from everything else.
I desire freedom.
The reason I am making this commitment to you is because I desire freedom.
That's Iyya kanaarbudu.
And Iyya kanastain is asking him for assistance in getting that job done.
So that's the second reason.
And the third reason is that we seek the closeness of Allah .
We desire the Qurb of Allah.
This is also the reason why this conversation switched from third person to second person, right?
Because when we say we are now directly speaking with Allah.
So it's a more intimate conversation.
And we're using that intimate conversation for two things, for worship and for assistance.
So, what scholars tell us is that what this verse teaches us is that we all want to be near and we all want to be dear to Allah.
We all want to be loved by Allah.
We want to be His beloved.
Right?
But the ultimate way to establish that nearness, that love of Allah, is by worshiping Him and by calling out to Him for assistance.
That's why in a hadith aqutsi
Allah very explicitly says my slave does not get closer to me more so than by doing what I have told him to do and that is the five times daily prayer so if you want to be close to Allah pray five times a day and keep calling him for assistance because there is no better time to call him for assistance than with prayer the next topic that I want to talk about is the sequence the
sequence in which these two things are used these two words are used right so if you look at it the first thing that is mentioned is Ibada worship is mentioned first and that is followed by Aun which is the assistance of Allah now why is that important because the sequence that you find in the Quran between things it's that is never coincidental right it always has a very specific purpose it's always very precise because this is divine this is divine revelation so
like nothing is just arbitrary in the Quran.
So why is worship mentioned before seeking assistance?
Because the best way to seek the help and the assistance from Allah, the best way to ask Allah for anything and everything that we may need or want is to ask after worshipping Him.
Abdullah ibn Masood, he would tell his students,
Save your needs and your necessities for the obligatory prayers.
So whenever you need something or whenever you're dealing with something difficult, a difficult situation, a challenge in life, don't worry.
There is going to be a obligatory prayer right around the corner.
Use that as an opportunity to ask Allah to help you solve your problems.
Not to say that you cannot remember Allah during the entire day, which obviously we should, that's the idea of Aun, right?
But the proper sequence, the proper protocol would be to worship Allah and then seek His assistance.
The last thing I want to point out is the hikmah, the wisdom in the repetition of this word iyaka.
So you can see that the word iyaka is used twice here, right?
iyaka na'abudu and then iyaka nastain.
So the word iyaka is repeated twice.
Now grammatically speaking, if Allah omitted the second iyaka, and if Allah had just said iyaka na'abudu wa nastainu, it is only you we worship and seek assistance from.
Right?
Just eliminate the second iyaka.
That would have been grammatically correct.
So then why did Allah repeat Himself when it's not grammatically necessary?
Does this mean that the second iyaka is not absolutely necessary to the meaning?
No.
And let's look at that.
So there's a wisdom behind that.
So when we say iyaka nabudu wa nastainu, when we remove the second iyaka,
Both words naabudu and nastainu they connect back with the same iyaka.
Which means they become associated with that iyaka.
But when I say iyaka naabudu wa iyaka nastainu they both now have their own iyaka.
So what that does grammatically is that it makes both independent of one another.
It makes worship and assistance independent of one another.
Why is that important?
Why did Allah do it this way?
Because Allah said worship and then seek assistance, right?
That's the optimal method.
That's the right protocol.
That would be ideal.
That's how we're supposed to do it.
But then there might be some of us who might have lost our way.
There might be some people who are not praying to Allah.
They're not worshipping Allah.
And yet, because of life, they just run into some difficulties or some tragedies.
And in that difficult moment, they need Allah's assistance.
They need Allah's help.
So Allah very subtly, He separates the two, just a little bit.
He makes them independent for the sake of the people to let them know that even if you aren't worshipping Me, even if you aren't praying to Me, don't worry, you can still seek My help and My assistance.
My door is still open to you.
Subhanallah.
So worshipping Me and then seeking assistance would be the ideal way in submitting yourselves to Me
Willingly, freely enslaving yourselves to me and then seeking my assistance, that would be the more logical way of doing things.
But even if you're not doing that, even if you're not worshiping me or enslaving yourselves to me or submitting to me, I will not deny my assistance to you.
You can still always turn to me.
You can still always come to me, talk to me.
I will still be there for you.
That's the beauty of iyyaka narbudu wa iyyaka nastaye.
Now, considering the relationship between a master and a slave, what is the slave constantly in need of from his master?
Commands, instructions,
Right?
If there are no instructions from a master, if there are no commands coming from a master, then technically that means you're free.
So as the Abd, we need some instructions from Allah, right?
Now the Arabic word for instructions is Hidayah, which comes from the root word Huda.
So the next logical progression in this line of thought
is that ya Allah now that I have enslaved myself to you now that I'm committed to you now that I'm depending on your assistance to fulfill my commitment what is it that you want me to do how can I pay off this debt of submission that I owe you how can I move towards you how can I get closer to you give me some instructions give me some hidaya
And so, the surah progresses into .
Guide us, instruct us towards the straight path.
Scholars point out something very important here in this sequence of declarations.
So we just learned that is a commitment, right?
It's a declaration, it's a promise, it's our sincere as we call it.
Right?
That is followed by a call for assistance, which is then followed by asking for instructions.
So if you think about the sequence here, we're not saying give me the instructions first.
If I think I'll be able to do them, if they make sense to me,
If I feel like, you know, I'm able to find the time to do them, then I will do them.
No.
All of that has already been covered in the earlier verses.
Right?
Starting from we are just making the commitment.
We're making that promise of that we will do whatever you tell us to do because that's all part of being a slave.
Right?
You don't become a slave and then say, you know, I'll do it when it makes sense to me.
The making sense of it was all done in the previous three verses.
Those were the verses that make us realize that Allah is worthy of our .
Those are the verses where we get convinced of Allah's mastery over us.
Right?
Those were the verses where we completed our homework.
where we did all our research they complete the theory portion of this whole message starting from now it's practical time it's all action and the reason this is important is because people ask this question you know why do we have to take ahead when as as Suleiman is when we take when we make this commitment people say that we know why do I have to make this promise why is this so important because that is the action of commitment
You can think and ponder and plan all you want, but until you actually commit to something, you cannot produce a change.
I mean, isn't that true in every aspect of our lives?
Weight loss, the biggest problem of our times.
We can read all about weight loss.
In fact, according to a study, obese people are usually the ones who know the most about losing weight, how they need to lose the weight.
Because they've read up so much about it, they've watched so many videos on this.
But until they commit to a lifestyle of good diet and a lifestyle of exercise, they cannot actually lose the weight, right?
So you have to make a commitment to produce change.
and this is why we have I commit only to you and I seek only your assistance and then we have guide us give us instructions so the more sincere we are in our commitment the more we can expect Allah to help us on our journey towards him so inshallah in the next session we will look at the remaining verses
Waakhruda wan alhamdulillahi rabbil alameen wassalatu wassalamu ala rasuli he saidina Muhammadan khatimin nabiyin wassaidul Mursaleen wala Akhi wa wassi Alibnabi Talib ashrafil wassiyin wa alal aimatimin zuriatima tahirin wassalim alayhi majmain al-Fatih.